What do you think, David?
What are the deep similarities here?
>> So, I picked that three of
these are deep similarities.
In both there's something
revolving around something else.
The planet revolving around the sun and
the electron revolving
around the nucleus.
In both,
there's a force between two objects.
A force between the sun and
the planet, and
a force between a nucleus and
an electron.
And in both,
two objects attract each other.
All three of these
are based on relationships.
The revolution,
the force between two objects and
the attraction between two objects.
I didn't pick the other three
because while these two are true,
they don't represent deep relationships.
And while this is actually true,
it's not actually captured
in our representation.
So this isn't part of our knowledge
base for the purpose of this problem.
Now we can see why the textbooks
write about this solar system and
the atomic structure in such a way that
these relationships become salient.
They help us make sense of the atomic
structure, but pointing to the deep
similarities between the relationship
that are occurring with the atomic
structure and the relationship that
are occurring in the solar system